tonight on the new reality
i don't understand how someone dies
during a wellness check
i'm pissed i'm outraged that outrage
from so many
led to protests this summer in canada
and beyond
are just they're not mental health
professionals we're the wrong entity
in the first place there's a space in
there for somebody other than a uniform
what's your fear my fear is that nothing
changes
st paul's hospital in vancouver the team
is doing detective work on the long-term
effects of covin
it does make me worry what about the
rest of my life
do you think you still fall into the
category of recovery
i still feel the impact of the virus
in my body i still feel permanently
changed
hello i'm donna friesen welcome to the
new reality
tonight we're examining a part of
policing that's intended to help those
in distress
but as we know from some tragic high
profile cases can escalate into use of
force
and death they're called wellness checks
police called to check on someone who is
feared to be in the midst of a mental
health crisis
but mental illness is not a crime
tonight farah nasser explores why
wellness checks go wrong
and what could make them right
it started as a call for help
chowdhury was 62 years old and suffering
from schizophrenia
his family was worried he wasn't taking
his medication
so they called a non-emergency line in
june
the father of four was shot and killed
we're here saying listen we need your
help let's go and de-escalate the
situation
what are we told be patient everything's
gonna be fine
we're not gonna hurt him we're not gonna
use any force and you can clearly see
the result of that
within three weeks three high-profile
cases of canadians
all in mental health distress all from
racialized communities
ended up dead
this is my sister she means so much to
me regis korchinsky pacquette fell to
her death from her toronto apartment
building on may 27
while officers were in her home police
were later cleared by an investigation
that her family disputes in edmondson
new brunswick officers went to chantal
moore's home to check up on her in
what's called
a wellness check police say moore
charged at the officer
with a knife the 26 year old
was shot dead we've been hurt many times
how can we ever trust any police force
why should we even answer the door for a
wellness check
how in the hell did that happen
her family and canada's minister for
indigenous services say it should never
have ended
that way i don't understand how
someone dies during a wellness check
frankly
along with many canadians indigenous
peoples living in canada
politicians i'm pissed i'm outraged
that outrage from so many led to
protests this summer in canada and
beyond
with the protests demands for real
change
to a broken system including calls for
police forces to have their
budgets reallocated to redirect some of
that money into community mental health
services
and to change the response for those in
a mental health crisis
to a medical call not a police response
but knowing that somebody on the end of
the phone is going to answer
and show a bit of you know compassion to
them and sometimes that's all
you know people want darna savara daily
is a crisis worker with the gerstein
center in toronto
for over 30 years gerstein has been
leading the way when it comes to mental
health support for people
in crisis testing center may i help you
offering a 24-hour crisis line and
mobile health teams that go into the
community to respond
and help those suffering in times of
crisis
its model is a non-police response with
a focus
on listening and hearing people's
concerns
we try to meet people where they're at
we try to be you know
not judgmental we try to acknowledge how
difficult
situation can be for somebody we try to
validate how they're feeling
you know we really give them that time
that they need to tell their story
and many more services like the gerstein
centers are needed
to take the time to do it right that's
where asante haughton and rachel
bromberg come in
they are trying to fundamentally change
how we respond to mental health crises
in canada
they co-founded the reach out response
network which advocates for a
non-police mental health emergency
service
available 24 7. what we hear really
consistently
is that police are just they're not
mental health professionals they're
limited in what they're able to provide
she says her group's research shows that
responding with a crisis team
is more likely to have favorable
outcomes compared to interactions
involving only the toronto police
service's
primary response units meaning frontline
officers
i think a big difference is the trust
that you have in the system asante has
been wary of calling police when dealing
with his own
mental health challenges because of what
he's witnessed firsthand
relatives being interrogated instead of
supported
when you're a racialized person you have
a variety of very justifiable reasons as
to why you don't have trust with the
system and that's probably because
you've been harmed by the system in some
way not just that the system hasn't
served you but you've been harmed by it
the visibility of someone showing up in
a police
uniform i think can escalate the
distress symptoms for someone who is
dealing with mental illness
dexter voice is the dean of the
university of toronto's faculty of
social work
and as we saw in those high profile
cases from this summer
he says race is one of several important
factors that make mental health calls
so difficult when dealing with
communities who are
already wary of police when you look at
the intersection
of gender place race and class
individuals who represent racialized
populations
poor populations tend to have poorer
more negative more deadly interactions
with police
back in peel region the same
jurisdiction where ijas chowdhury
was killed we met with the police chief
and the head of the canadian mental
health association
the two groups are working together
though he wouldn't go into specifics of
the chowdhury case
chief nishan duryappa readily admits
that police are not
the ones for the job when it comes to
many mental health calls
do you have anything to say to ejaz
chowdhury's family who
who say that there should have been you
know a better response to the way this
this was handled
yes and you know i'll say it again that
you know we too
uh are heartbroken for the tragic loss
of life
uh our role is to preserve life and to
prevent
uh these incidents from happening but
we're not mental health professionals
police are still the default first
responders for everything from noise
complaints to mental health calls
and now even top police authorities are
admitting
that the system needs to change and
is changing finally there's broad
attention
to the fact that we've been seen as the
panacea for every social
uh ill whether it be homelessness
addiction housing
youth related issues in peel police and
the canadian mental health association
have partnered
to deliver a mobile crisis response team
known as
msert crisis workers joint officers on
mental health calls
the problem is there aren't enough of
them do you think there are enough in
peel region right now
for any given shift absolutely not
there's 1.4 million people in this
region and we have
two m-cert cars out at a time
the chief says his force receives about
7 000 mental health calls a year
the two mobile units are only able to
respond to less than
a third of those the bigger question is
should the police be involved at all
earlier this month new york city
announced it's launching a pilot crisis
response to dispatch
trained crisis workers instead of police
for some 911 other large cities like
denver
already have similar initiatives pretty
much everybody we see
is for one reason or another in a state
of crisis in eugene oregon
a civilian-led approach integrated into
the 9-1-1 system
has been in place for years members of a
mobile response team
known as cahoots are dispatched instead
of police
when a non-police response is deemed
appropriate
by an emergency dispatcher or through an
emergency line
cahoots received 24 000 calls in 2019
police backup was required just 150
times
we're the wrong entity in the first
place there's a space in there for
somebody other than a uniform david
smith
from the canadian mental health
association along with other mental
health advocacy groups
say the response needs to be flipped so
that a mental health call is
always met with a health response first
and then a police response if and only
if
it's needed what are police doing right
but also what are some of the mistakes
they're making right now
i think if if there's something that
police can do in terms of an area of
improvement it's
it's involving us more in those
mental health calls but we don't have
the resources
uh to be there so we need resources and
then we're available
and then i think there's a willingness
actually to to hand over that
responsibility to health care
which you don't always see another
challenge with mental health is the
belief that people in crisis
often become violent so a police
response is needed
but advocates for change say that's not
the case
there is a stigma there is an
association that people have in their
minds between mental health crisis calls
and violence
but in the real world it just doesn't
exist
what all agree on is the terrible
history
of those in a mental health crisis
ending up dead
has to stop what's your fear
my fear is that nothing changes
my fear is that you know this moment is
a moment and it's not a movement
coming up on the new reality the main
things i'm still dealing with right now
are
really disabling fatigue even working at
a computer
has been really difficult how many
people might be long haulers
anywhere in the range of two and a half
percent of people will still have
symptoms at
12 weeks after symptom onset and that's
probably a conservative estimate
it won't be long before we're looking at
2020 in the rearview mirror
at some point the pandemic will end and
life as we knew it before covid will
return
but there is a group of people whose
lives may never return to normal
they're known as the long haulers they
got coveted and survived but are
plagued by a multitude of symptoms that
are as debilitating
as they are mysterious robin gill takes
us inside
canada's first post covid clinic trying
to solve the enigma
of the long haulers
katie mclean has a lonely life she can't
go anywhere
can't see anyone because of what copin
19 has done to her health
it's discouraging and worrisome but all
of our lives are
pretty different now with with the
pandemic but
this takes it to like such a different
level it's very isolating
mclean's isolation started in september
when she tested positive for the virus
then her symptoms took over cough
shortness of breath
a racing heart and the worst part
debilitating exhaustion
when we met up with the 42 year old nine
weeks after her diagnosis
she's still suffering from those same
symptoms even taking the stairs
is too much the main things i'm still
dealing with right now are
really disabling fatigue even working at
a computer
has been really difficult i can't really
physically or mentally exert myself
without having
a relapse of symptoms mclean is part of
a new group of patients called
covet long-haulers a term used to
describe those who have symptoms
well after the virus has left their
system you're considered a long hauler
does that
title worry you it does make me worry
makes me worry about
you know what about the rest of my life
and and what's that going to look like
and will i be able to resume regular
function and be active again or is this
kind of
what i'm going to be dealing with for a
long time he said one zero
it's an eerily similar story to
jacqueline robinson's
she too is suffering from long-haul
covet symptoms
robinson got sick during the first wave
in march and for the first week she was
isolating at home
her health started to spiral she ended
up spending eight days on a ventilator
in a medically induced coma and in a
warped twist of fate
robinson who is a nurse went from
helping patients
to needing life-saving care needless to
say i was
shocked and scared her husband and kids
weren't allowed to visit
and when she finally emerged from the
hospital two weeks later
robinson was down almost 12 pounds and
her muscle strength
had wasted away it is terrifying
to have a virus that's completely novel
i am a nurse
i like to make sense of things and the
hardest part of this whole experience
for me
is there's no answers at st
paul's hospital in vancouver canada's
first post-covet clinic
the team is doing detective work on the
long-term effects of covid
so far there's one main trend i'm seeing
a lot of a lot of suffering dr jesse
griner is a general internal medicine
specialist and the director of the
clinic
i just want people to feel like they're
not alone in this that we're all
sort of in this together is your mind
like churning all day long and all night
long when you see your patients and
you're thinking about this
i'm at home i'm trying to like research
and understand different different
syndromes and different ideas and
yeah i'm learning as much from them as
they are for me right now take a big
breath in quickly
the answers may be found in the 160
patients they're treating because
they're also the backbone of crucial
research
so i'll explain each test first the
clinic is conducting its first study of
postcovid patients
and mclean is one of them i could
breathe but i felt like i was breathing
heavily
for the next two years of her life
she'll be going through a series of
tests to understand
how she became a long hauler do you feel
like a guinea pig
i do a bit because we don't we just
don't know
how this is going to play out yet every
time mclean visits
she'll be getting an ultrasound and ecg
done on her heart
a ct scan of her lungs
pulmonary test to see how her lungs are
handling the weight of it all
how exhausting is all of that on top of
having covert
from being a person who pre-covered you
know would
be going to work and then yoga classes
and seeing friends and and now i'm i
really have to
plan the day to kind of conserve the
energy i have
so it's hard yeah it's exhausting so
what could be causing the extreme
exhaustion
really we don't we don't know the answer
at this stage that's because the
long-haul condition
is so new it's impossible to know how
many people could be in this category
but there's a growing number of patients
all over the world
who say they have long coveted i always
knew it was covid and i was told very
early on it was coped
hannah davis believes she got coveted in
march
at the time she lived in new york city
the epicenter of the virus in the united
states early
on the hospitals were completely
overflowing
they really were trying to keep us away
from the hospital they explicitly said
if you're out of breath while you're
walking across your room
that's not good enough to come into the
hospital when davis finally did get
tested it was
31 days after the onset of her symptoms
when i got tested the doctor said
this isn't really worth doing after 14
days these tests are worthless
this is going to come back negative and
it did davis is now part of a
long-hauler support group
many of whom say they were infected but
told to stay home
so they never had a positive test the
more common experience is that you get a
negative test and your doctor says oh it
wasn't covid
it must be something else and then
you're on not only you know a goose hunt
for um what it actually was which was
kobit
but you're also just you know paying
insane medical bills
how many people might be long haulers
you have any sense of numbers
yeah i mean if you believe the study in
the uk it sounds like
anywhere in the range of two and a half
percent of people will still have
symptoms at
12 weeks after symptom onset and that's
probably a conservative estimate because
some people don't even recognize that
the symptoms that they are having are
related
in the scientific world the closest
thing doctors have to compare cova 19 to
is sars and there are only a handful of
studies looking at the long-term impacts
of the 2003
outbreak on those who recovered a
university of toronto report followed 22
people with sars
and found they were not able to work for
almost one to three years after
infection
participants had persistent fatigue
muscle pain
and depression what you're doing is
physically right researchers at st
paul's hospital say those studies are
helpful but they're not enough to
understand this new virus
that is likely permanent covid is is
really here for the
the long term this isn't something that
we're going to have go away
through good infection control policies
which essentially is what happened with
sars
dr christopher ryerson is a leading
expert in the study and treatment of
patients with lung disease
the vast majority of people will have
normalization or very near normalization
of any symptoms over the
coming months after their initial acute
infection
there will be some people who are quite
unwell who will have persistent scarring
in their lungs and that could have an
impact have you taken anything for the
fever
jacqueline robinson is now back at work
it's been almost nine months since her
time in the hospital
she has good days and bad but robinson
still doesn't know if this is her new
normal
do you think you still fall into the
category of recovered
i feel like i'm recovering however i
still feel the
impact of the virus in my body and i'm
not back to my baseline
i still feel permanently changed it's
the reason robinson has teamed up with
the postcovid clinic at st
paul's both as a test subject and a
nurse working in the clinic
so she can see this disease from the
lens of a medical professional
and a patient the thing that's
interesting about my case is they don't
understand why some
people under the age of 50 with no other
chronic health conditions
could get such a severe impact like
severe version of this virus
i can tell you that i'm seeing a lot of
people under the age of 50
that are having sort of ongoing symptoms
i'm seeing people over the age of 50 as
well
coincidentally both robinson and maclean
are the same age
42 for katie mclean she's focused on
getting better
she hopes the testing will one day help
her escape the impact of covid
and the waves of exhaustion that rule
her life
it's going to be a long haul for the
research as well are you prepared for
that
i think advocating about it is really
important and being a part of the
research is really important
to help other people you know and
hopefully
the more we know less people will have
to go through this
and have their lives kind of severely
turned upside down by
by this infection
next week on the new reality i didn't
really feel
like human you make money so that you
can live
but i wasn't making enough money to live
what a basic income does is
provides a foundation from which
people can grow you see entrepreneurship
you see employment you see people doing
better in their lives overall
to have the capacity to live the human
experience and
have relationships and have a healthy
lifestyle
and it's really hard to do that when
you're poor every canadian deserves to
live in dignity and a wealthy country
like
ours we can afford to pay for
and that is the new reality for this
week thanks for watching
you